how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and there is just
a ton of things happening right now
within the marvel cinematic universe and
over at marvel studios
it looks like marvel studios is kicking
things back up again going full throttle
ahead starting production on all of
those projects that were halted
because of kovid and now starting
production or getting ready to start
production on new projects such as thor
love and thunder
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness the hawkeye series and
the she-hulk series we recently got our
official she-hulk casting tatiana
maslany
is going to be playing jennifer walters
aka she-hulk but now we have a report of
another casting call for she-hulk and
that is
a young bruce banner and this also means
really big news for adult bruce banner
and the hulk and i'll talk about
everything you need to know in this
video but first big congratulations to
youtube user bika dimension for being
the winner of last week's cyclops
giveaway
just email me in the email in my
description and i'll get you your prize
and for this week's giveaway we're going
to be giving away a loki
funko pop so all you have to do to enter
subscribe like this video leave a
comment down below
so today's news is coming to us from
thedirect.com
and in their report they say that they
have exclusively learned that she-hulk
is set to feature a younger version of
bruce banner
marvel studios is currently casting an
actor around the age of
10 years old for the role so this is
indeed
a very young bruce banner a 10 year old
bruce banner
so it seems fairly obvious what they're
doing with casting a young bruce banner
for the she-hulk series
as you may or may not know jennifer
walters aka
she-hulk is the cousin of bruce banner
so obviously with the casting of a
younger
10 year old bruce banner they're going
to explore the backstory between
jennifer walters and bruce
they're going to show us the past back
in time when they were kids
then of course they're going to work
their way up to what we assume will be
present day after the events of avengers
in game where jennifer walters gets into
an
accident and in order to save her life
her cousin
bruce banner aka the hulk does a blood
transfusion with her to save her life
now this ends up being successful
but he also transfers some of that hulk
blood into her and she ends up becoming
she-hulk so this is actually pretty cool
news because we're not just going to get
a present day jennifer walters we're
going to see a lot of the backstory of
bruce banner
and this is involving bruce banner in a
much different way than we've ever
really seen him in the mcu
now the fact that we're getting a young
bruce banner pretty much confirms the
fact that we're going to get a present
time bruce banner who is currently
professor hulk
but from what we've heard marvel has
much different plans for the hulk moving
forward so we may not have professor
hulk for long
but mark ruffalo has already stated that
he wants to appear in she-hulk and of
course in the series they're going to
show how she becomes she-hulk and that
involves the hulk so mark ruffalo and
bruce banner are coming back but we
could perhaps get a very interesting
story before then
with the casting of a younger bruce
banner this means that marvel could want
to explore bruce banner's relationship
with his family who he was
before the hulk and who he was before
the hulk actually
contributes to him as the hulk you see
in the comics when bruce is younger he
didn't exactly have
a good relationship with his father in
fact it was actually quite abusive in
nature
and it was a pretty emotional storyline
but a storyline that led to the origins
of the hulk and the only time we've
really seen a story concerning bruce
banner on screen is either right before
he becomes the hulk
or after not much is really known about
him before even in iron man number one
we learned a little bit about tony stark
before he
became iron man and then even in captain
america civil war we learned a little
bit about his relationship with his
parents even more and they've done this
a few times in the mcu we've explored
the relationship between thor and odin
loki and odin star-lord and ego and it
looks like we're about to find
out a little bit about natasha's family
in black widow so this is definitely
something that marvel would do and a
very different perspective to show
for the hulk and perhaps we're going to
get a little bit of that
in she-hulk so mark ruffalo is going to
be returning as
bruce banner aka the hulk and we are
going to be getting a 10 year old
bruce banner and she-hulk let me know
what you think about this news and how
excited you are for this and if you had
it your way
moving forward what hulk story would you
like to see happen in the mcu
let me know in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof